bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur Public
Sénat après les événements tragiques de
la semaine dernière les travaux
parlementaires reprennent peu à peu un
cours normal les sénateurs examinent en
ce moment l'un des projets de loi phare
de ce début d'année le projet de loi
nôre pour nouvelle organisation
territoriale de la République qui
répartit les compétences entre les
différents échelons il examine ce matin
l'article 2 qui porte sur les
compétences des régions en matière de
développement économique alors d'un côté
il y a le gouvernement qui veut donner
un maximum de pouvoir à ces nouvelles
grandes régions développement économique
donc innovation route collège et de
l'autre les sénateurs de la majorité qui
ont peur et bien que l'on ne déshabille
le département pour habiller la région
avec en filigrane la crainte de la
suppression de l'échelon départemental
vous allez le voir les événements de la
semaine dernière pèsent lourdement sur
les débats certes chacun campe sur ses
position certes il peut y avoir des
tensions mais les débats restent très
respectueux et très feutrés tout de
suite direction l'hémicycle pour la
séance l'ordre du jour appelle la suite
de la discussion du projet de loi
portant nouvelle organisation
territoriale de la République dans la
discussion des articles nous sommes
parvenus à l'amendement numéro 405 au
sein de l'article
2 dont euh nous allons euh aborder 14
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune et l'amendement
numéro 121 rectifié bis est présenté par
Monsieur le Président
yest merci monsieur le président à la
suspension cette nuit nous avons
réfléchi
à
préciser ce que la Commission vous
proposait déjà parce que je rappelle
qu'il y avait un amendement que je vous
avais annoncé d'ailleurs un amendement
1021 qui précisait les compétences des
diverses collectivités en dehors de la
région et donc notre amendement nous
l'avons complété puisque nous rappelons
explicitement pour permettre à chacun de
ne pas être obligé de se référer à tout
moment au code général les collectivités
territoriales parce que c'est ça dont il
s'agit les compétences des
interc munalité il faut pas dire il faut
pas de la métropole de
Lyon les autres métropoles étant pour
l'instant des intercommunalités c'est
pas la métropole de Lyon je vous le
rappelle un statut spécifique faut pas
l'oublier parce que qui figure
d'ailleurs dans un titre particulier
désormais du Code Général des
Collectivités Territoriales quand on
parle métropole il faut pas parler et
peut-être il y aura d'autres métropoles
qui auront d'autres structures saiton
jamais madame la ministre
h on en parlera sans doute avant la fin
de nos
débats donc l'objet c'est de dire ça
n'exclut pas les compétences bien
entendu des des interco alors c'est tous
les articles que nous citons de la
métropole de Lyon nous l'avions déjà dit
mais nous le il on
et il faut rappeler que les départements
d'abord il y a la solidarité
territoriale qui leur permet d'avoir un
certain nombre d'action et d'autre part
elles peuvent les départements avec la
région peuvent très bien organiser des
actions mais c'est en vertu de l'article
1118 et l
155012 du Code Général des Collectivités
Territoriales
c'est
conventionnel donc je crois que parce
que c'est vrai que il y a tout un tas
d'actions de promotion et cetera qui
pourront être organisés avec la région
la seule chose c'est que la le monopole
d' l'attribution des aides à terme enfin
à terme c'est vraiment la région parce
que si on naccepte pas ça c'est même pas
la peine de faire de loi franchement
hein et la région élabore à cette fin
chez régional de développement
économique d'innovation et
d'Inter
internationalisation nous déclinons
après les la la manière dont on élabore
le schéma et je vous rappelle que le
schéma c'est une coélaboration on a été
vraiment aussi loin qu'on pouvait il y
avait même il y a même l'intervention de
la conférence territoriale de l'action
publique s'il y a un désaccord entre une
majorité de de des interc et la région
et ben on peut revenir donc vraiment on
a été jusqu'au bout pour à la
fois dire clairement dire clairement que
nous attribuons la compétence économique
à la
région mais elle n'est pas la seule
parce que quelquefois on dit elle est la
seule pas vrai les interc par la loi
toutes les interc le développement
économique c'est de leur
compétenence et vous êtes obligé même
une communauté de commune vous êtes
obligé de mettre le développement
économique parce que donc c'est les
communes en fait mais qui délèguent
obligatoirement puisque je rappelle que
la compétence générale des communes fait
quand même que quand on a délégué une
interco obligatoirement ou
optionnellement les communes perdent
cette compétence c'est c'est le régime
des intercommunalités donc je crois
monsieur le prés monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues
que ça clarifie ce que ce qui n'avait
peut-être pas été compris par tous en
craignant que la région
ne ne tiennent pas compte ne tiennent
pas compte à la fois des compétences des
uns et des autres et des possibilité de
travailler en on verra d'ailleurs les
conventions plus tard à l'article 3 donc
c'est la proposition que vous fait la
proposition rectifiée que vous fait la
commission des lois
merci monsieur le rapporteur la parole
quel est l'avis du Gouvernement madame
le ministre vous avez la
parole sur l'ensemble des
amendements ah oui
d'accord monsieur le Président je
voulais pas m'exprimer sur un amendement
sur les amendements mais simplement
puisque hier soir ça n'avait pas été
possible redire dans dans quel esprit
nous avions nous avons déposer le texte
d'abord et et comment il il peut évoluer
on est était nous étions ici
gouvernement et parlementaire
nombreux à être d'accord pour redire
compris Gérard Colomb pour dire qu'il
était important que les régions de
France
et un rôle majeur en terme de stratégie
économique
définition des politiques d'IDE directes
dont elles ont la responsabilité seule
et surtout le lien Recherche
Développement Innovation et ce et C on
avait vraiment cet accord enfin il m'a
semblé lors de la discussion de la loi
maptane qu'on avait C cet accord puisque
effectivement quand a été voté la partie
du texte à l'époque sur les métropoles
les questions avaient été posé des
régions et nous avions trouvé dans le
débat le moyen de bien Serrier les
choses effectivement comme on se le
disait hier soir une région ne va pas
s'occuper de l' immobilier d'entreprise
à tel ou tel endroit une pépinière
d'entreprise un incubateur si une
collectivité veut le faire elle sera
applaudie on n'a pas du tout
à interdire on était bien sur cette
stratégie globale mais à encourager et à
permettre aux régions d'avoir un rôle
extrêmement fort de stratégie
industrielle qu'est-ce qui nous manque
en France depuis la fin du 20e siècle
c'est une politique industrielle c'est
une politique de développement des
nouveaux emplois on a reconnu le fait
urbain et les métropoles parce qu'elles
sont moteurs et tout le monde le sait et
personne le ditit il y a pas de souci
sur cette appréciation en revanche il
nous manque effectivement euh cet
engagement de tous pour que on puisse
définir une politique industrielle le
gouvernement d'ailleurs s'y emploie avec
les projets d'avenir et un certain
nombre de de d'axe de travail qui ont
été déterminés mais nous avons besoin
que les régions fassent ce travail aussi
et d'ailleurs après beaucoup de débats
internes au gouvernement et public
ensuite la question s'est posée des
pôles de compétitivité du fait que le
gouvernement gère beaucoup trop l'État
en gère 70 pardonnez-moi c'est pas le
gouvernement l'État en gère 70 c'est
beaucoup trop il faut que des régions
soient en capacité de gérer des pôles de
compétitivité de déterminer d'ailleurs
d'autres axes de pôles de compétitivité
et je vous rappelle enfin dans
notre dans notre
volonté redresser la France et de
permettre au territoire d'y participer
nous avons créé cette conférence
territoriale de action publique et nous
avons essayé d'écrire un texte qui
puisse permettre que de nouvelles
compétences parce qu'il y aura de
nouvelles compéten un jour qui aurait
cru qu'on discuterait aussi longtemps de
numérique il y a quelques années il y
aura des innovations importantes qui
vont venir heurter tous nos textes et il
est important que la façon dont nous
écrivion avion soit clair pour les
régions leur responsabilité et
naturellement prennent en compte
l'action des métropoles et des
intercommunalités on en a parlé souvent
ici au cours de du premier débat les
régions ne doivent pas perdre trop de
temps t cadre temps finance aussi sur de
l'immobilier d'entreprise sur un
aéroport qui a une fonction particulière
parce qu'il n'est autre chose qu'un
simple aéroport est la seule façon pour
une zone de pouvoir vivre il y a des cas
particuliers de ce type donc il n'est
pas question que les régions puissent
ici là partout effectivement on a
longtemps discuté aussi avec la RF
intervenir surtout et en particulier sur
le mobilier d'entreprise moi je pense
que l'idéal c'est pourquoi je prends la
parole c'est que sur des compétences que
nous allons découvrir en marchant je
mets de côté les aides directes sur
lesquel il faut être extrêmement ferme
extrêmement ferme il y a 6000
interventions aujourd'hui économiques en
France non il faut être extrêmement
ferme les aides directes il y a un chef
de fil absolu parce qu'il en a la
compétence donc il n'est même plus chef
de file il est responsable c'est la
région il faut être extrêmement ferme
mais après il faut que la conférence
territoriale d'action publique sur tel
ou tel sujet qui va arriver dans telle
région ou dans telle autre qui ne sera
peut-être pas de même nature puisse
prendre une décision et que la loi le
permette donc je je crois
que dire trop haut que la commune
revient dans le développement économique
est tile dans la mesure où la clause de
compétence générale le bloc communal l'a
et que la recherche de
rationalisation nous importe faisons
attention à ce que nous écrivons mais
moi je seraai pas
arquebouté ici on aura deux lectures
puisque le Premier ministre s est
engagé il faut qu'on puisse
être clair ce texte veut
rationaliser veut clarifier et veut
rendre plus opérant nos collectivités
territoriales puisque à la fin du 21 du
20e siècle nous avons choisi la
politique des services et oublié la
politique industrielle ne revenons pas
sur les raisons avançons et je dis un
dernier mot parce que hier soir ça n'a
pas été possible sur ce que disait
madame l'éat nom de la commission
économique sur l'obligation d'avoir des
contrats entre la région et ce que
certains appellent les pays les pôles
les bassins d'emploi les bassins de vie
et cetera et cetera c'est des contrats
infra depuis longtemps déjà nos régions
passe des contrats de ce type je pense
que ça ne peut pas être dans la loi euh
j'entends votre volonté et j'ai même
envie de dire votre plaidoyer hier soir
parce qu'il était excellemment conduit
mais c'est vrai que ça ne peut pas être
dans la loi parce qu'ensuite en fonction
des région de leur façon de fonctionner
il faut leur laisser la main pour
organiser ce dialogue singulier entre la
région et les disons les pays entre nous
peu importe l'appellation ou les bassins
de vie ou les bassin de vie économique
je crois qu'effectivement les les
régions ont souvent ou toujours fait ça
et et je pense que nous n'avons pas à
écrire dans la Loire comment elles
doivent le faire et là aussi moi je fais
confiance aux élus à la CTAP pour
trouver la meilleure façon les contrats
infrarégionaux on a vu en Bourgogne on
en a vu en franchecté on en a vu en
Bretagne on a quitain et ailleurs et
même en île defance donc je pense que
c'est important que soit pas je conclus
en disant faisons attention à notre
écriture avant que d'autres s'exprime il
faut je crois que le citoyen français
qui nous entend nous écoute et va lire
le projet et bien entendu et bien
entendu que la région a un rôle majeur
déterminant en terme de stratégie
économique de développement économique
d'internationalisation des entreprises
il faut que tout le monde l'ai entendu
non obsent bien sûr les capacités très
grandes des autres pourquoi parce qu'il
y a des régions sans métropole il a des
régions où il n'y a pas de métropole ou
alors les métropole sont petites faisons
attention à ce que notre volonté d'avoir
une
coopération coopération entre les
territoire ne plus jouer uniquement sur
la concurrence ou le dumping en
territoire soit au rendez-vous donc il
faut que notre texte prenne en compte
tout ça et que la coopération entre les
territoires pour redresser la France
soit vraiment à notre ordre du jour
merci madame la ministre je vous
rappelle que nous avons 14 amendements
en discussion commune mais compte tenu
de l'intérêt que suscite cet amendement
rectifié proposé par la Commission des
lois et de la demande exprimé par un
certain nombre de nos collègues je vous
propose de donner la parole ça fera une
mini euh je dirais un mini débat avant
de d'examiner les autres amendements je
suis sûr que le il y aura peut-être un
certain nombre de retrait donc le
premier avoir demander la parole est
d're collègue ad vous avez la parole mon
cher collègue merci monsieur le
Président je pense que vous avez eu
raison de souligner que ça pourrait
entraîner le retrait de certains
amendements ce qui fait que ça ne sera
pas du temps perdu
donc je voudrais avoir un certain nombre
de précision et je voudrais être précis
moi-même il n'est pas question pour les
départements de demander à pouvoir
disposer des aides directes c'est la
région qui s'en occupe actons-le il n'y
a pas de problème mais je voudrais poser
deux deux questions de manière à ce
qu'on puisse m'éclairer et que le débat
puisse servir ensuite à argumenter parce
que dans l'amendement qui nous est
présenté je veux saluer le travail de la
commission il est dit en fonction des
responsabilités économiques des
départements mais euh je vais dire
derrière cette phrase encore faut-il que
ailleurs il n'y ait pas suppression
totale de euh du du droit à au
développement économique des
départements mais je vais vous poser
deux questions il y a 2 ans j'ai une
entreprise phare dans le département de
l'Aube qui s'appelle les andouillettes
de 3 et euh qui a des difficultés
financières
bien il faut acheter l'immobilier pour
que l'entreprise puisse continuer à
fonctionner elle le loue normalement ça
n'est pas une aide directe il y a
acquisition de l'immobilier la région
refuse d'y venir le département se
retrouve seul avec l'agglomération
aroyenne et une petite aide de l'État
est-ce que j'ai encore la possibilité
est-ce que le département a encore la
possibilité de le faire dans un cas
comme ça où la région dit moi je ne veux
pas y participer autre exemple il y a 4
ans une une entreprise célèbre
puisqu'elle fabrique des cycles Peugeot
et qu'elle équipe aujourd'hui la
totalité des facteurs en France a des
difficultés il faut racheter
l'immobilier de
l'entreprise c'est le département qui
l'achète aider très largement par l'État
la Région refuse d'y participer elle y
vient à hauteur de 300000 2 ans après
est-ce que nous avons le droit de
continuer à le faire nous avons équipé
une zone d'activité logistique 250
hactares c'est le département qui est
pilote les communes étant trop petites
est-ce que nous avons le droit de
continuer à commercialiser les lots pour
des entreprises qui veulent s'y
implanter en fonction des réponses qui
vont mettre à porter la main maintenant
je retirerai l'amendement suivant et je
me réjouirai du travail de la
commission merci mon cher collègue la
parole est au président
rotillot oui d'abord merci monsieur le
Président d'avoir accepté de disjoindre
cet amendement vous l'avez parfaitement
compris il est important et il va
éclairer l'ensemble de de nos débats
donc merci d'avoir pris cette initiative
madame monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je voudrais vraiment remercier
Jean-Jacques Kest et Philippe B euh pour
l'effort qu'ils ont fait euh de
rectifier l'amendement que la Commission
avait présenté je pense que c'est
important euh chaque terme doit être
pesé simplement pour resituer le débat
euh je voudrais dire que le choix que
collectivement nous avons fait c'est de
ne pas supprimer un échelon en clair de
ne pas supprimer le département de dire
non lorsque à l'époque le Premier
ministre nous a proposé en 2020 de
supprimer le département tout vient de
là
pour le faire la stratégie qui été
développée par Philippe B et
jean-jacquesest a été de dire non à la à
la suppression d'un échelon oui à la
clarification et à une forme de
spécialisation des compétences deè temps
3è temps dans la spécialisation nousous
sommes tous accordés pour dire que le
travail de métier de la région devait
être la préparation de l'avenir et que
dans ce bloc de compéten devait lui
échoir la stratégie notamment économique
autre point il ne s'agit pas à travers
le schéma
régional qui va définir une stratégie il
ne s'agit pas de faire de façon cachée
un
jacobinisme économique régional et de
charger la région sur l'ensemble de son
territoire de toutes les actions
économiques elle ne le pourrait pas
notamment dans le cadre de grandes
régions qu'à ce momentl elle embauche
des milliers
de collaborateurs sans doute plus sur le
territoire national donc nous sommes sur
un schéma qui exprime des orientation
définie par la région que des
intercommunalités dans le cadre de la
conférence territoriale peuvent d'abord
refuser pour forcer la région du reste à
redélibérer et j'aimerais que tous nos
collègues relisent attentivement elle
paraît au contre-rendu analytique la
déclaration préalable que le rapporteur
jean-jacquesest a pris soin de faire
hier il a été je pense trop peu ou trop
mal écouté mais il faut lire cette
déclaration euh l'amendement rectifié de
ce matin finalement tire les
conséquences et euh clarifie explicite
la déclaration préalable de Jean-Jacques
yest moi je pense que beaucoup de nos
sénateurs je pense à Brigitte micolo
hier je pense à Jean-Pierre Grand hier
aussi et d'autres se sont inquiétés ils
se sont inquiétés par parce qu'on sait
parfaitement que au-delà de nos idées
qui tendent à faire à chaque fois de ces
exercices de réorganisation des
compétences de collectivité territoriale
un exercice de géométrie euclidienne
mais on sait très bien les exemple que
Philippe ADNA a indiqué que sur les
territoires de très très grandes régions
les régions du haut de leur métropole
régional ne pourront pas tout régir par
conséquent elles devront impulser une
orientation et elles devront déléguer
conventionner avec d'autres
collectivités qui gardent la clause
générale de compétenence qui auront la
loi leur permet le code général des
collectivités territoriales les y
autorise à faire des conventions et je
souhaite que cette vision réaliste qui
concilie le principe de spécialité de
spécialisation avec le principe de
réalité d'efficacité économique parce
qu'au bout du bout c'est ça c'est la
lutte contre le chômage je pense que tel
qu'il a été exprimé tel qu'il a été
explicité dans l'amendement rectifié je
pense que cette rédaction correspond et
répond aux inquiétudes de la plupart de
nos collègues je voudrais en ce sens
remercier le président bas et notre
rapporteur merci de votre attention
merci mon cher collègue la parole est en
françois
patria monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre chers
collègues monsieur le rapporteur bon
j'ai vu ce matin les négociations à la
salle des conférences entre le
rapporteur auteur des amendements pour
se mettre d'accord sur l'écriture d'un
texte qui pourrait donner satisfaction à
tout le monde quand on veut faire
plaisir à tout le monde c'est pas comme
ça qu'on avance j'ai le sentiment ce
matin que je vais avoir politiquement
tort
étanttant minoritaire je vais avoir
juridiquement tort étant politiquement
minoritaire mais je m'interroge non je
m'interroge quand même sur la poursuite
d'un processus qui vise à tout geler à
ne pas avancer à ne pas clarifier et au
bout du compte à ne pas économiser je
vais vous donner un exemple dans le
numérique pourquoi ça n'avance pas
pourquoi ça n'avance pas sur le
territoire parce qu'on a fait des
scoranes et on a fait des sedentes il y
a une ch cohérence faite par la région
puis le département qui fait son schéma
et je préside momentanément une région
où il y a quatre départements où il y a
une scorane aucun département ne fait la
même chose le problème n'avance pas
chacun a son propre certain c'est la
montée en débit d'autres c'est la je pas
interrompu Monsieur R vous savez on se
respecte tous les deux je vous
interromps pas d'accord bien et ça
n'avance pas et qu'est-ce que font les
départements ils viennent simplement
voir le président de région pour dire
j'attends de la région qu'elle me donne
30 40 50 millions point la ligne
laissez-moi faire ce que je veux c'est
mon schéma c'est le mien ben ça va être
pareil demain ça va être pareil avec le
développement économique moi je pense
que si si les trains fonctionnent bien
c'est parce que la région s'en occupe
seule si les bus fonctionnent bien c'est
parce que le département s'en occupe
seul et si l'é marche bien non pas seule
la région mais que ce soit elle qui
puisse décider j'avais cru comprendre
que l'essence même de ce texte que les
déclarations du chef de l'État et du
Premier ministre était de dire les
régions ce sera l'économie et voilà
qu'on veut les mietter l'éparpiller
alors j'ai entendu tout le monde fait de
l'économie les communes l'interco les
départements les métropoles les les
agglomérations tout le monde en fait et
tout le monde en fait mieux que les
autres mais qu'est-ce qui va se passer
demain je plains le futur président de
la Région pasa quand les deux métropoles
à Marseille et à Nice auront décidé de
se faire ce qu'elles veulent que
restera-t-il au président bah il ira
sans doute s'occuper des chèvres en
Haute Provence oui il ira à gape il ira
quelque part mais il ne s'occupera plus
du développement économique chers
collègues non et puis par contre là-bas
on lui dira dans la métropole non
écoutez vous êtes bien gentil monsieur
le Président mais moi j'ai décidé pour
mon université pour mes incubateurs pour
l'innovation de le faire et puis venez
simplement payer ce que vous me devez ça
suffira donc moi voilà je je suis un peu
déçu parce que je comprends pas
aujourd'hui j'ai bien vu que je dois
être le seul présent de région ici
d'ailleurs je le suis depuis pas mal on
est deux ou un ou deux pas beaucoup de
conseillers régionaux alors je vais vous
faire une proposition un amendement dans
ces conditions puisque tout le monde
fait tout et le fait bien là il faut
supprimer les régions madame la ministre
puisque les régions aujourd'hui elles ne
sont que des guichet on va simplifier
les territoires on va enlever un échelon
on va gagner en économie on fera tout
donc à la à la limite je ne voterai pas
cet amendement bien entendu d'ailleurs
je pense que cet amendement sera sera
battu à l'Assemblée nationale et je
l'espère demain je l'espère demain je ne
voterai pas je ne comprends pas
aujourd'hui que sur un sujet aussi
sensible que celui de l'emploi
développement économique on continue à
avoir des guerre picrocoline gauloise je
sais bien qu'alisia est en Bourgogne
mais je pensais qu'on l'ait un peu
dépassé merci merci mon cher collègue la
parole monsieur le Président vous
souhaitez intervenir en ce
moment je vous donne la parole monsieur
monsieur le Président je vous remercie
madame le ministre monsieur le ministre
je vous salue mes chers collègues
aussi
de bien rester près du texte dans nos
interventions je serais malheureux chers
collègue patria que vous considériez que
l'amendement de clarification qui a été
présenté par notre rapporteur au nom de
la commission doivent conduire à
supprimer les
régions gardons dans nos propos les
proportions qui nous permettent de
dialoguer au plus près de la réalité du
texte qu'est-ce qui se passe en réalité
nous avions un projet de loi du
gouvernement qui reconnaissait en
matière économique que la région était
la collectivité territoriale responsable
de la définition des orientations en
matière de développement économique je
dois vous dire que le texte de la
commission que nous allons amender avec
un amendement de la commission était
plus
régionaliste que le texte du
Gouvernement puisqu'il en venait à
préciser que non seulement la jour
définissait des orientations et il
faut
être conscient qu'une orientation ça
n'est pas une obligation non seulement
la région définit des orientations en
matière de d'économie mais nous
ajoutions dans une phrase qui comportait
quelques renvois à des numéros
d'articles elle est seule compétente
pour décider des interventions
économique sur son territoire
et cette avancée en faveur des régions a
paru excessive à beaucoup de collègues
qui nous ont dit et le bloc communal et
la métropole de Lyon et mon
agglomération et nous avons répondu dans
un premier temps rassurez-vous chers
collègues tout a été prévu les mentions
des
article X Y et Z qui sont aussi dans le
texte permettent de couvrir ces
préoccupations mais vous nous avez dit
moi je voudrais de la sécurité juridique
et nous avons répondu cette nuit en
essayant dans un ultime effort de
clarifier notre rédaction par le la
proposition d'un amendement qui vise à
répondre à ces préoccupations du bloc
communal de la métropole de Lyon des
agglomérations mais aussi des
départements qui dans le débat ont porté
euh la voix de collectivité qui euh
réclament de pouvoir par délégation de
la région essentiellement continuer à
intervenir dans certains domaines et
dans le cadre fixé par la région
autrement dit premièrement le projet du
gouvernement était moins régionaliste
que le texte de la Commission le texte
de la commission qui était plus
régionaliste que celui du gouvernement
comportait déjà des renvois aux
compétences que peuvent exercer d'autres
collectivités ces renvoie n'était pas
suffisamment clair nous vous proposons
de les clarifier pour que la commune au
titre de sa clause de compétence
générale qui ne disparaissait de toute
façon pas dans aucune des rédactions ni
celle du gouvernement linal autres
puisse continuer à intervenir de même
que la métropole et la et
l'agglomération qui doivent pouvoir
avoir des responsabilité dans le
développement économique local à partir
du moment où naturellement on n'est pas
en contradiction avec des décisions
prise au plan régional et donc on en
arrive maintenant à avoir été très clair
sur le rôle de chacun on n'a pas créé de
compétences nouvelles pour les communes
la métropole de Lyon les agglomérations
et cetera ni pour les
départements on a au contraire supprimé
pour le département la compétence
économique qu'il exerçait de manière
générale et en revanche on ne supprime
pas au plus près des réalités
économiques des compétences qui
s'exerçaient et que ni la commission ni
le gouvernement n'avait voulu supprimer
les choses allaient peut-être sans le
dire mais elles vont encore mieux en le
disant et c'est l'objet même de
l'amendement dont nous discutons qui
n'est pas un amendement rédigé par une
sorte de complot aux porte de
l'hémicycle mais un amendement de
clarification proposé officiellement par
la commission pour permettre de faire en
sorte que chacun y trouve son compte
tout en affirmant bien clairement et
très fortement une compétence régionale
plus clairement affirmé encore que dans
le texte du
Gouvernement merci monsieur le Président
la la parole est à monsieur
Sueur monsieur le Président merci
madames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers
collègues hier soir entendant le débat
j'étais pr frappé par la confusion de
celui-ci ce matin voyant le nouvel
amendement présenté par notre rapporteur
Jean-Jacques
yest j'ai cru voir avancée qui m'est
apparu salutaire
entendant mon ami François patria à
l'instant je voulais
intervenir pour dire comment je perçois
cet
amendement il ne faudrait pas en effet
qu'il y ait des lectures très
différentes qui aboutissent à ce qu'on
ne comprenne pas ce que souhaite le
Sénat il est clair que si cet amendement
voulait dire cher François patria que
tout le monde fait tout ce serait un
recul et vous auriez tout à fait raison
de vous
insurger je comprends cet amendement
comme nonamment en
rien la principale innovation de ce
texte est peut-être le seul progrès
sensible qui résultera de la lecture au
Sénat puisque sur bien dans bien des
domaines nous arriverons très
probablement à du statut quo à la suite
de cette lecture par rapport à ce qui
existe
présentement pour moi ce qui est
essentiel c'est que ce texte affirme
clairement la compétence économique des
régions le rôle est clairement
mentionner indiquer la région c'est la
collectivité de l'économie bien donc il
faut le dire et le redire parce que il
faut le dire et le redire parce que si
tel n'est pas le cas ce que nous faisons
n'a aucun
sens en même temps j'ai compris moi que
l'adjectif seul posait un réel problème
il posait un problème par rapport au
fait que l'on maintenait la compétence
générale des communes et par conséquent
la compétence général en la matière qui
peut-être délégué aux
intercommunalités mais il posait surtout
un problème de
fait parce que si la région a un rôle
éminent en la matière il est clair qu'il
y a une armature urbaine qu'il y a des
communautés des métropoles et que
cellees-ci forcément interviennent dans
le processus économique
forcément donc il s'agit de dire
l'impulsion la compétence c'est la
région et d'autre part il y a une phrase
qu'a prononcé notre rapporteur et qui
pour moi est tout à fait essentielle
monsieur le rapporteur Jean-Jacques yest
vous avez bien dit que les aides
économiques seraient du ressort des
régions donc elles seront à l'origine et
ce sera leur rôle à elle d'attribuer les
aides économiques cela dit chacun
comprend bien qu'avant d'attribuer
l'aide économique il n'est quand même
pas interdit de dialoguer avec la grande
ville ou d'ailleurs la moyenne ville ou
la petite ville où se situe
l'implantation industrielle existante
qu'il faut aider conforter ou à venir
qu'il faut
créer donc pour moi cet amendement n'a
de sens
que s'il conforte l'intuition initiale
du texte ce qui lui donne sens région
économie rôle majeur de la région dans
l'économie des régions fortes sur le
plan économique mais en lien avec
l'armature urbaine avec les métropoles
avec les communautés car sans cela on ne
peut même pas régler un certain nombre
de questions pratiques donc je tiens à
intervenir lourdement excusez-moi de le
faire de cette manière pour dire que si
on donne l'interprétation tout est dans
tout et réciproquement et donc tout cela
ce sont des paroles creuses
effectivement nous aurons mal
travailler si on
affirme le rôle éminent de la région
tout en disant qu'il n'y a pas une
exclusivité parce que dans les faits
c'est pas possible je crois qu'on aura
fait un pas en en avant par rapport à la
force des régions de notre pays je vous
remercie merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Favier
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre je vourrais aussi à mon tour
appuyer cet amendement qui je crois
effectivement est un amendement de
clarification un amendement utile
personne ne conteste ici le rôle majeur
que les les régions doivent jouer en
matière de développement économique je
dirais même que on le souhaite par
exemple en île-de-fance moi je
souhaiterais qu' compris action
régionale soit encore plus forte dans ce
domaine qu'elle ne l'est aujourd'hui
mais pour autant l'économie ne peut pas
être l'exclusivité d'un niveau de
collectivité c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous nous sommes favorables à
ce que la région soit d'ailleurs plutôt
plus que responsable plutôt chef de fil
de cette action qu'elle aille plus loin
et compris dans son intervention
peut-être d'ailleurs en se dispersant
moins dans d'autres actions qui sont
aujourd'hui menées dans l'activité
régionale pour se concentrer peut-être
davantage sur cet enjeul-l qui des con
conséquence évidemment considérable et
très importante notamment pour faire
reculer le le chômage donc pour nous il
n'y a pas de problème en la matière pour
autant les autres niveaux de
collectivité continuent évidemment ont
un rôle à jouer si on prend la question
des départements moi je préside un
département d' 1300000habitants c'est
pratiquement parfois plus que parfois la
population de certaines régions on ne
peut pas évidemment être en dehors de
l'action économique mais dans un cadre
qui doit être redéfini par exemple
aujourd'hui nous finançons nous les de
compétitivité je pense que c'est pas
notre rôle je crois qu'effectivement
c'est plutôt à la région de le faire
mais pour autant est-ce qu'on doit se
désengager complètement d'une action
dans le domaine économique ça n'est pas
possible par exemple actuellement nous
le plus grand chantier sans doute un des
plus grands chantiers au monde va
débuter sur cette région c'est la
réalisation du Grand métro Express c'est
dans mon département 5 milliards
d'investissements qui vont être réalisés
il faut déplacer des entreprises euh qui
va faire ce travail de déplacement des
entreprises par exemple est-ce qu'on va
gérer ça l'échelon régional ou est-ce
qu'il faut travailler avec les outils
dont on dispose nous nous avons une
agence de développement qui en quelques
mois a permis de relocaliser ses
entreprises très rapidement parce que il
y a une un lien une une coopération une
proximité avec le milieu économique qui
a permis de le faire sans pertere
d'emploi sans perte de de dans dans dans
des conditions donc cette agence est
utile elle est efficace je dirais même
elle est plus efficace certainement que
l'agence régionale pour autant demain
moi je ne suis pas contre évidemment que
cette agence soit éventuellement une AG
une en quelque sorte une une agence
déconcentrée au niveau départemental de
l'agence régionale mais faisons
attention de ne pas du jour au lendemain
sous prétexte de vouloir confier à la
région l'exclusivité en quelque sorte de
l'action économique arrêter bloquer tout
ce qui d'ors et déjà est à l'œuvre et
qui permet aujourd'hui au contraire de
d'accompagner donc on a besoin davantage
je dirais de coopération entre l'échelon
régional et échelon départemental sans
doute que de ce point de vue il y a des
progrès considérable à réaliser et qui
ne le sont pas malheureusement toujours
je crois qu'il y a plus un travail un
développement d'une politique
contractuelle qui doit être redéveloppé
les départements je suis tout à fait
d'accord sur le fait qu'il n n'est plus
à verser des aides directes aux
entreprises d'ailleurs nous sommes
toujours assez réservés sur ce sur ce
sur ce plan pour autant
au titre de sa compétence en matière de
solidarité territoriale il est évident
par exemple que les départements doivent
continuer à travailler pour favoriser le
développement de l'économie sociale et
solidaire qui sont un des outils pour
nous pour permettre la mise en œuvre de
nos compéten par exemple en matière
d'insertion sociale des populations en
difficulté donc voyez donc je crois
qu'il y a cet amendement est important
parce qu'il permet de clarifier les
choses il n'enlève rien aus régions mais
il clarifie de manière je crois positive
la manière dont nous pouvons travailler
à l'avenir merci mon cher collègue la
parole est au président
mzard merci monsieur le président madame
monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je ne suis pas
convaincu que le travail réalisé sur la
base du projet de loi du gouvernement
avec la participation du Parlement
aboutissent une finé
à une
simplification du fonctionnement de nos
institutions
territoriales la responsabilité en
incombe je le dis d'abord au
gouvernement par
rapport à la manière dont les textes ont
été
hachés présentés dans le
désordre sans que l'on commence par le
début d'ailleurs ou au moins par ce qui
devait aller avec c'est-à-dire la
question des ressources des
collectivités territoriales
et l'amendement que nous avons
aujourd'hui que nous allons soutenir
c'est un peu l'utilisation de rustine
sur des pneus
percés car mais mais mais mais c'est
utile oui c'est
utile la réalité et elle était très pas
sous-jacente elle s'exprimait très
clairement hier soir et comme en
commission j'étais très sensible
aux explications de notre collègue
Gérard Colomb pourquoi en arrivons-nous
à ce type de
difficulté d'abord parce
que il y a une ambiguité mais qui est
plus qu'une ambiguité c'est que très
clairement et c'est encore dans l'exposé
des motifs de son texte le gouvernement
a visé dans son
texte la suppression des conseils
départementaux et que très clairement
c'est ce qui soutend c'est ce qui
soutend sa position qui est
respectable mais comme il s'est passé un
certain nombre d'événements et ben il
faut quand même faire avec les conseils
départementaux encore que j'ai entendu
il y a quelques jours une interview de
Monsieur le Ministre
Vallini et j'ai et j'ai et j'ai eu le
sentiment que la question des conseil
départementaux n'était pas forcément
définie
tranché mais tout cela entraîne une
ambiguité constante totale parce
qu'autant madame la ministre on peut
entendre oui nous ne voulons plus de
département mais à partir du moment où
on fait avec tout en voulant faire 100
on fait mal et c'est ça la réalité qui
va amener encore plus de
complexification qu'avant c'est
inéluctable parce que pourquo pouroi
pourquoi des
métropoles pourquoi des départements
intercommunalités parce qu'il faut dire
que quel que soit leur taille
aujourd'hui les
intercommunalités communauté de commune
communauté d'agglomération Métropole
Communauté urbaine elle porte la réalité
du développement économique sur leur
territoire et sur leur territoire elles
assurent la péréquation et
l'équité je reviendrai pas sur le débat
sur l'égalité d'hier soir je parle
d'équité or les régions de par de par
leur composition politique de par leur
système électoral sont disons-le sauf
celle de notre excellent collègue patria
le plus le plus souvent coup des
réalités de terrain et veulent imposer
des systèmes plus
idéologiques que correspondant au aux
véritables besoins de nos collectivités
et de nos territoires et cette dualité
avec d'un côté ce système représentatif
des régions
aggravé par la fusion de grandes
régions ce ce système totalement
différent de la représentation de nos
territoires dans nos intercommunalités
avec les représentants des exécutifs qui
sont sur le terrain qui développent qui
font le travail et bien cela va aggraver
la fracture territoriale j'en suis
convaincu tout cela n'est pas clair
n'est pas raisonnable n'est pas réaliste
voilà ce que je voulais dire alors nous
voterons cet amendement parce que il a
il a une vertu c'est de préserver je
dirais l'essentiel mais cher François
patria si toutes les régions
fonctionnent selon les méthodes que vous
utilisez il y aurait moins de
débat malheureusement ce n'est pas la
réalité et pour conclure je vous dirais
quand on a assisté à l'audition des
présidents de région ici au Sénat le mot
qui revenait dans leur bouche le plus
souvent c'était lequel pouvoir pouvoir
pouvoir moi je suis un jacobin national
et je ne veux pas l'émiettement du
jacobinisme
régional merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Pierre Yve
Colomba pour prolonger ce que vient de
dire mon Président je dirais que si nous
qui sommes ici nous avions constaté par
un dynamisme évident de la région en
matière de développement
économique nous serions moins réticant
si le projet de loi
prévoyait pour les régions de nouvelles
ressources financière pour animer cette
politique
économique par exemple sur ce modèle
rêvé de l'Allemagne en matière de
mobilisation de l'épargne
locale en tiers de modification
d'utilisation de la banque publique
d'investissement nous serions moins
rétiscant si en même temps que nous
discutons de des compétences des régions
et des autres
collectivités nous nous étions posé la
question du mode de scrutin du mode de
désignation
des assemblées régionales et
donc de leur président de façon à être
vraiment représentatif des territoires
ce qu'elles ne sont pas actuellement
nous serions moins
rétissant donc et c'est pour cela je
crois que l'effort qui a été fait par
par notre collègue la nuit en plus est
tout à fait méritoire et est tout à fait
méritoire et c'est pour ça que je crois
que nous nous le voterons ceci
dit je n'ai pas pu m'empêcher à la
lecture de ce de ce texte de penser que
décidément n nos nos lois deviennent de
plus en plus
illisibles alors mon cher collègue c'est
sûr vous avez introduit de la clarté
est-ce de la lumière et j'ai pensé à ce
verre du C c'est vraiment une obscure
clarté qui tombe qui tombe des
étoiles merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur
colon merci bien monsieur le Président
moi je veux
remercier le président de la commission
des loi et le
rapporteur d'avoir fait le travail
qu'ils ont fait entre 1h du matin et
notre reprise de séance parce que je
crois que cela va nous permettre
d'avoir une appréciation qui soit
commune pratiquement sur tous les bancs
de cette
assemblée lorsque nous avions le débat
hier on ne remettait pas en cause le
fait que les régions puissent avoir un
rôle majeur en matière
d'économie ce que l'on remettait en
cause c'est le fait que la compétence
soit un moment
exclusive et donc prive de la capacité
d'action un certain nombre d'autres
territoires je dira même que
quelquefois pour les régions sur le plan
économique nous ne trouvons pas qu'elles
en font
trop nous trouvons même qu'elles n'en
font pas assez mais nous voulons
justement parce que il a cette
interrogation avoir la capacité
d'action pour ce qui concerne les
grandes agglomérations et c'est pas
hasard si hier beaucoup se sont exprimés
qui étai de ces grandes
agglomérations le phénomène de
métropolisation puisqu'on parle de
métropole c'est pas la taille d'une
agglomération c'est le fait que tout
d'un coup sur un
territoire se cristallise un certain
nombre de fonctions supérieures
d'université de recherche de startup
d'innovation c'est cela qui fait la
métropolisation évidemment si ceux qui
sont la tête des métropoles se
désintéressaient totalement de ce qui
fait l'essens même du territoire où ils
sont franchement faud les supprimer
parce que ça noffrirait plus aucun
intérêt donc je crois que nous sommes
arrivés à un bon équilibre
et j'espère que dans la suite du débat
cet équilibre sauvegardé moi je ne suis
pas pour qu'on se livre des batailles
rangées entre les métropoles et les
régions et que on peut mobiliser les uns
l'Association des Régions les autres la
CUF l'association des communautés
urbaines de France et cetera même la MF
qui hier s'est inquiété après avoir
regardé un peu la teneur de nos débats
moi je suis pour qu'on trouve des
accords et je crois que monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président avec
votre amendement vous nous proposer un
point d'équilibre moi je retirerai donc
mon amendement et je voterai le vôtre
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur gréier
oui monsieur le Président Madame le
ministre monsieur le ministre cher
collègues moi aussi je voudrais rendre
hommage au à la proposition et je me
retrouves très bien dans cette
proposition qui est faite par notre
rapporteur avec cette idée de chef de
fil n'oublions pas elle est très très
équilibrée effectivement cette
proposition n'oublions pas que la région
se retrouve aujourd'hui aussi chef de
fil des crédits européens donc cette
dimension lui donne une autorité
supplémentaire sans pour autant enlever
les réalités territoriales de proximité
telles qu'elles sont proposées première
remarque deuxième remarque
dans notre proposition et et les
compétences de la région il y a le
domaine de la formation on ne peut pas
dissocier raisonnablement aujourd'hui
quand on
voit les manquements parfois les le
grand écart qui peut exister entre les
formations qui sont proposées ce qui est
les les femmes et les hommes qui sont
sur le marché de l'emploi et par rapport
à la réalité des besoins de l'économie
il y a vraiment cette nécessité de chef
de fil et de cohérence entre le domaine
de la économique et le domaine de la
formation dernier point que je voudrais
aussi
évoquer c'est quand même aussi l'aspect
du du
fonctionnement cette
décision cette proposition dans laquelle
je me retrouve très bien va avoir
d'autres conséquences mais c'est pas
l'objet aujourd'hui c'est la définition
des ressources des régions parce
qu'effectivement devenir chef de fil
sans moyen ça veut plus rien signifier
donc effectivement mais je veux pas le
rentrer dans le débat à cet instant mais
ça montre bien la dimension et la
portter de ce compromis qui est proposé
mais surtout de cette lisibilité qui
nous est proposée donc je m'y retrouve
très bien à une petite remarque prête
qui ne concerne pas non plus le débat
d'aujourd'hui il faudra aussi avoir le
courage de donner aux régions des
exécutifs qui ne sont pas a
Tage donc effectivement où aujourd'hui
quand on voit le lapse de temps parfois
l'impossibilité pour des raisons où on
coupe parfois trop souvent les cheveux
en quatre sur le développement
économique par rapport à d'autres pays
ou d'autres régions européennes on peut
s'interroger mais là aussi c'est pas le
débat d'aujourd'hui mais nous devrons
avoir le courage de le trancher on ne
pourra pas prendre en otage l'économie
et le développement économique de nos
régions mais je voulais féliciter nos
rapporteurs et je soutiendrai cet
amendement merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur
montuger Merci monsieur le Président
chers collègues je trouve
personnellement que effectivement cet
amendement apporte des des précisions
des éléments de de
clarification toutefois je j'essaie de
me projeter dans la la mise en œuvre de
ce qui pourrait résulter de cette de ces
disposition je ne trouve pas beaucoup de
de de changements par rapport à la
situation sit que nous vivons
aujourd'hui
cependant la la compétence renforcée de
la de la région va se traduire par
l'élaboration donc d'un schéma régional
de développement économique
d'internationalisation et
d'innovation il me semble la question
que je me pose je souhaiterais avoir si
c'est possible une une réponse ce schéma
va-t-il être
opposable voilà et comment cette
opposabilité éventuelle va se uire euh
dans les relations entre les différentes
entités euh parties prenantes du
développement économique d'un d'un
territoire
euh voilà
euh les décisions que que prendra que
prendra la région euh en matière de
d'implantation économique d'orientation
économique euh vont-elles vont-elles
s'imposer aux territoires qui par
ailleurs euh vont garder euh euh des
responsabilités en matière de
développement économique le bloc
communal les départements évidemment en
particulier voilà c'est j'essaie de me
projeter dans la dans la mise en œuvre
personnellement je je je trouve que cet
amendement apporte des éléments de de
clarification et je le je le voterai
mais je crois qu'il y a voilà cette
cette question de l'opposabilité se se
pose et la manière dont on pourra la
faire vivre et et la question se pose
aussi de manière encore plus accrue me
semble-t-il de la de la façon dont le
schéma régional va être élaboré dans la
concertation avec l'ensemble des des
parties prenantes territorial merci
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
monsieur
Bouvard oui monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je va pas
retarder les nos travaux mais donner
acte à la Commission et la remercier de
de cet amendement parce que c'est vrai
que ce que l'on peut attendre d'une loi
telle que celle-ci c'est qu'il y ait
plus d'efficacité à l'arrivée qu'il y
ait des plusvalues et qu'il n'y ait pas
des moinsvalu par destruction de ce qui
existe et ce qui fonctionne or tout en
souscrivant totalement au discours
exprimé hier par le sénateur maire de
Lyon sur le fait que la richesse est
concentrée aujourd'hui dans les
métropoles qui sont les lieux de
créativité il y a sur le territoire
national dans la diversité des
territoires des territoires qui sont
avec des modèles économ inversé en
quelque sorte et pour être l'élu de l'un
de ces territoires lorsqu'on regarde le
territoire savoyard regroupé dans les
deux départements ce qui était quasiment
équivalent à la population de l'Auvergne
la richesse elle n'est pas créée dans la
zone urbaine elle est créée dans les
vallées c'est là qui est concentré
l'énergie c'est là qui est concentrée
encore la majeure partie de l'activité
industrielle liée à la présence de
l'énergie et c'est là qui est concentré
l'activité touristique avec la première
destination mondiale pour les sports
d'hiver et c'est les vallées qui
irriiguent la ville et dans ce contexte
c'est vrai que les départements ont un
rôle historique parce qu'ils ont porté
l'essentiel des parcs d'activités tous
les grands parcs d'activité de Savoie et
de haut Savoie les technopôes sont
portés par des outils départementaux
directement ou sous forme de syndicat
mixte et il est important évidemment
qu'on puisse poursuivre cette action
donc le texte tel qu'il est rédigé
réaffirme la primauté de la région qui a
la compétence mais éclaircit le point de
délégation possible de cette compétence
aux structures départementales qui
peuvent continuer à jouer leur rôle
fédérateur et leur rôle d'interface
entre l'économie des vallées et
l'économie des zones urbaines il y aura
un autre problème qu'on aura traité mais
j'aurai un amendement tout à l'heure
pour cela c'est le problème évidemment
des zones frontalières compte tenu du
fait qu'il y a aussi un certain nombre
de territoires dans notre pays où la
majeure partie de la richesse et des
emplois sont dépendants de métropole qui
sont en dehors du territoire national
que ce soit bal d'une part s'agissant du
Nord enfin du sud de l'Alsace ou que ce
soit Genève s'agissant des départements
savoyard et Delin merci mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
dantech
oui le le le temps est au consensus dans
dans
l'hémicycle je je ne partage pas du tout
ce ce consensus euh Dieu sait
qu'avec le président yes nous avons de
forts désaccords y compris sur les
marges de manœuvre que nous donne la
Constitution mais je trouve que la
manière dont il a présenté hier la la
première proposition de la de la
Commission en insistant sur le fait de
de sortir de l'enchevêtrement et de
donner de la lisibilité que c'était le
sens de de cette loi et le travail qui a
été fait fait par la commission sur le
la question du développement économique
en maintenant le le schéma me me
semblait moi un travail assez courageux
assez
courageux honnêtement honnêtement ce mot
sous réserve des interventions
économique moi me fait très très peur
pour pour l'avenir on avait un vrai
problème et Gérard Colomb l'a beaucoup
exprimé hier sur l'articulation
métropole région de toute évidence
les choses n'étaient pas calées entre
les deux vrais lieux aujourd'hui du du
développement économique et donc là il y
avait un temps de travail mais en
profiter pour remettre le département
comme un acteur économique important je
pense et je pèse mes mots que c'est un
l'heure je pense même que le sousréserve
va revenir à de la part d'un certain
nombre de régions à aide-toi le Ciel
t'aider et et que ça c'est extrêmement
dangereux l'idée du schéma régional
l'idée de la réforme de la taille des
régions c'était aussi de forcer les
régions à faire de l'égalité
territoriale et c'est
l'amendement de pierre Jarlier qu'on a
voté hier avec cette
nouvelle rédaction ça veut dire que nous
pouvons être dans une situation où les
régions diront à des départements qui
sont plutôt des départements
périphériques plutôt des départements
faibles et peu dotés ah ben non nous on
y va pas vous y allez pas vraiment B
évidemment ils en ont pas les moyens et
que donc je pense que cette cette
lecture évidemment le président mard
sera pas d'accord mais on est
profondément désaccord sur la manière
dont évolue ce ce pays je pense que
aujourd'hui tel qu''est cet amendement
on perd en capacité d'égalité
territoriale et on réduit la
responsabilité de la région de de faire
du développement territorial équilibré
ça ne je pense qu'on avait d'autres
possibilités pour rééquilibrer
effectivement entre région et métropole
parce que là on avait un enjeu majeur
mais le compromis qui a été trouvé il
n'est pas étonnant dans cet hémicycle
par rapport au parcours politique des
uns et des autres à mon avis réduit la
responsabilité de la région et va se
retourner contre les territoires les
plus faibles je je je je pense que ma
lecture n'est probablement pas celle qui
est la plus partagé dans dans l'émic
mais en tout cas moi je ne voterai pas
cet amendement merci mon cher collègue
don à l'issue de cette mini discussion
générale nous allons monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez la parole
ouais un certain nombre se sont
inquiétés hier il y en a certains
s'inquiétaient aujourd'hui d'autres la
compétence de la
région la commission des lois ne la
remet pas en cause
et je vous rappelle que par contre il
est utile non non c'est pas nous qui
avons décidé de par la loi que les
métropoles auraient des compétences
économiques c'est la loi maptable pour
la ville de pour la métropole de Lyon
c'est les toutes les textes concernant
les
interc depuis toujours puisque je vous
le rappelle en permanence attendez en
permanence Monsieur Le
Dantec et la métropole
alors pour les départements et ça me
permettra de répondre rapidement à à
monsieur le Président
adud c'est que bien
entendu quand il s'agit de solidarité
territoriale c'est ce qu'on vise il y a
des solidarités territoriales et ça ça
veut dire que normalement les interc
devrai aussi s'en occuper et il y a
toujours la possibilité de délégation de
conventionnement et C et ça va pas
disparaître est-ce que les départements
vont continuer à être
mettouvrage de grandes zones
logistiqu normalement c'est plutôt de la
compétence des
interc ce qui ne veut pas dire que par
contrat et cetera d'une certaine manière
indirectement le département puisse s
contribuer par ses voiries et cetera
mais je pense que si on veut
dire
et puis il y aura le il y aura quand
même la CTAP il y aura un débat il y
aura les interc qui seront dans la CTAP
si si on pense que il y a rien de
changer je pense qu'il faut quand même
accepter parce qu'autrement c'est pas
possible il faut bien accepter des
évolutions ceux qui ne veulent pas
accepter les évolutions de même que je
ne veux pas de villeétat
enfin je ne veux pas de veétat il ne
peut pas y avoir de veétat qui sont
complètement étrangère à leur
environnement il ne peut pas y avoir
d'autres collectivités qui sont de
toutes les compétences et qui assume
toutes les
compétences que dans le passé que dans
le passé et sans doute parce que
certaines collectivités n'ont pas joué
leur rôle je le dis certaines pas pas
l'éminent pas bien sûr la région
Bourgogne qui est en pointe en matière
de développement
économique
hein pas seulement non mais puis oui
enfin ils ont é des tas de choses qui
font que la
Bourgogne dans sa diversité n'est-ce pas
agricole enfin et cetera bon he viticole
oui en moi je disais agricole pour pas
trop préciser
mais c'est comme la Champagne ça bon et
dont l'au fait partie d'ailleurs je le
rappelle avec d'excellents vignobles bon
donc euh non à terme à terme monsieur le
Président vous ferez des ça sera la
responsabilité en matière de zone
d'activité et cetera c'est c'est la
responsabilité des interc des interc et
si la région ne s'implique pas et bien
en fait c'est c'est c'est mais ça sera
dans le cadre du schéma tout ça il faut
accepter qu'il y ait des évolutions mais
en même temps et alors par contre la
solidarité territoriale on va le
préciser dans l'article sur le sur
lorsqu'on viendra au
département je pense que tout ce qui
concerne justement le le les petites
entreprises le département doit
continuer à avoir son rôle parce que
c'est certainement pas de diimension de
la région l'aide au commerce rural par
exemple parfois c'est par des contrats
mais on sait très bien que sont des
contrats passés d'ailleurs c'est pas
directement c'est pas le département qui
aide directement mais il va aider la
commune à racheter le boulanger le fond
du boulanger est-ce que la région si
veut le faire tant mieux chez vous chez
vous chez vous chez vous mais pas pas
dans d'autres régions ils savent même
pas qu'il peut y avoir des boulangeries
dans le monde rural enfin je vais bon
donc
voilà voilà le le terme du débat en tous
les
cas monsieur le président la le problème
qui va se poser c'est que l'amendement
de la
commission est en concurrence avec tout
un tas d'amendements c'est ce que
j'allais dire à la suite de votre
intervention monsieur le Président
discussion commune ça va êre intéressant
puisque la plupart des auteurs des
amendements nous ont dit que le nôre
leur plaisait une ceux qui étaient
présents ceux qui sont pas là les
amendements tombent donc on va procéder
bon je je le disais à l'instant nous
avons fait une une mini discussion
générale sur le sujet et ça me semblait
intéressant donc on va quand même
appeler les amendements parce que on
pourrait passer contre mais c'est une
procédure un peu spéciale je préfère
continuer dans la tradition du Sénat à
nous inscrire là-dedans et je vais
appeler la sagesse des sénatrices et des
sénateurs pour que nous ayons assez vite
alors dans la discussion générale nous
avions donc 14 amendements le premier
amendement qui est maintenant un
amendement de référence a été présenté
et longuement
discuté on le fera à la fin si vous
voulez puisque nous allons par rapport
par rapport excusez-moi donc c'est par
rapport au président alors je vous donne
la parole madame la
ministre bon donc vous avez la parole
madame la ministre par rapport à ce qui
nous sommes deux avoir ENF le
gouvernement de ont demandé la parole
and vini également
euh nous avons
euh découvert bien évidemment cet
amendement ce matin en début de de
séance je je vous dis tout de suite que
le gouvernement ne sera pas favorable à
son
écriture non pas parce que c'est une
opposition systématique je souris à une
réflexion qui a pu m'être faite hier
soir lorsque nous avons proposé ce texte
c'est après la loi maptane que vous dont
vous savez qu'elle a été votée et
qu'elle est donc maintenant le
droit dans cette loi
et Monsieur con le sait bien les
compétences des
métropoles ont été écrites décrites
elles sont précises et elle reste donc
il n'y a pas d'inquiétude à
avoir dans une métropole
par exemple au vu de la proposition que
nous avions faite et et je pense qu'on
est peut-être en train d'oublier que c
ces textes sont en
continuité l'un de l'autre notre
position la position du gouvernement
était
simple et je redis hier qu'effectivement
nous avons actuellement 6000 dispositifs
d'aide aux entreprises sur l'ensemble du
territoire français que nous avons tous
convenu ensemble que c'était énorme et
que malheureusement ça n'aboutissait pas
un
redressement de notre pays nous voulions
nous voulons toujours continuer à
affirmer le rôle de la région en qualité
de collectivité territoriale responsable
de la définition des orientations en
matière de développement économique sur
le territoire régional la région
disposant d'une compétence exclusive
pour définir ses orientations au travers
du schéma là effectivement elle est la
seule du schéma de développement
économique d'innovation et
d'internationalisation d'aide aux
entreprises donc aide aux entreprises
donc soutien à l'internationalisation
donc aide à l'investissement immobilier
à l'innovation des entreprises les
autres collectivités territoriales
puisque c'est ça le sujet depuis hier me
semble-t-il conserveront des
possibilités d'intervention économique à
savoir des aides contribuant au
développement économique quelle que soit
la forme de ces aides dans le respect
des orientations définies par la
région et Madame lard avait raison
hier je parle de l'idéal avec son accord
dans le cadre d'une convention et nous
avions pris soin rappelez-vous dans le
débat de prendre le cas des départements
qui n'ont plus la compétence de
développement économique sénateur posa
la question non le département n'a plus
soyons clair on se cache pas derrière
son petit doigt dans cette histoire n'a
plus la compétence économique en
revanche et on l'a dit depuis le début
et ça a été l'explication une des
explications les plus fortes que nous
avons donné sur la création de la CTAP
est-ce que les régions y compris avec
leur taille actuelle pour certaines vont
intervenir sur le dernier commerce en
milieu rural sur l'intervention
économique c'est-à-dire l'agrandissement
de tel immobilier d'entreprise qui en a
besoin Besin la recherche d'un terrain
l'accompagnement en verdé que sais-je
encore non il est hautement probable
sinon certain que les région vont
conventionner sur un certain nombre
d'interventions économiques y compris
avec les départements et peut-être en
premier lieu avec des département donc
c'était bien ça notre état d'esprit
c'est ça que nous avons expliqué pendant
la loi qui a été ici discuté et j'avais
l'impression jamais la certitude mais
que nous étions assez en accord l'idée
étant pilotage cohérence coordination
clarification et
efficacité c'est pourquoi les métropoles
avait ce statut particulier sinon à quoi
servait-il de créer les métropoles donc
nous avons été clair dès le premier
texte et je
continue puisque ce département pardon
en matière d'immobilier d'entreprise
seul les EPCI à fiscalité propre se voit
réserver une possibilité d'intervention
autonome en encadré cependant par les
orientations du schéma et c'est
peut-être aussi là que ça pose question
parce qu'on est encadré par
l'orientation d'un
schéma le
département se voit supprimer je viens
de le dire la quasi totalité de ses
compétences en matière de développement
économique de plus il ne dispose plus de
la clause de compétence générale qui lui
permettait d'intervenir
jusqu'à ce qu'une loi soit votée en la
matière
concrètement dans le texte de
gouvernement le département n'intervient
qu'en complément de la région comme je
viens de l'illustrer par quelques
exemples d'immobilier mais mais aussi on
en avait parlé souvenez-vous d'un
magasin à Maret ici d'une zone d'une
petite zone aéroportuaire là et
cetera donc nous sommes dans le cadre de
la
délégation nous discutons en conférence
territoriale de l'action publique parce
que je fais confiance aux élus on ne
peut pas légiférer même si on a des
expériences difficiles peut pas
légiférer parce qu'un tel et un tel
n'ont jamais pu s'entendre la loi ne
peut pas prendre en compte ce type de
situation d ce PCI à fiscalité propre
dispose de l'essentiel de la compétence
vous l'avez rappelé madame la rapporteur
au titre de la commission économique en
matière de développement économique du
bloc communal les communes peuvent
intervenir dès lors qu'un intérêt local
le justifie et que que la loi n'attribue
pas la compétence au profit d'une autre
collectivité ou d'un EPCI ainsi en
matière d'aide aux entreprises le bloc
communale doit respecter les
orientations du
SRDI tout comme les départements ne peut
intervenir en matière d'aide
principellement qu'en complément de la
région et il dispose néanmoins d'une
compétence de plein droit c'est-à-dire
d'une possibilité d'initiative en
matière par exemple d'immobilier
d'entreprise nous pensions avoir apporté
tous les éléments de clarté
de clarté parce que c'était ca dont nous
voulions discuter les uns avec les
autres dans la
rédaction je défends donc la rédaction
telle qu'elle avait été déposée par le
gouvernement après avoir essayer de bien
démonter remonter tous les articles pour
être précis précis parce que la
précision s'impose notre texte je viens
de le
résumer dans le texte de la commission
il y a une phrase qui a été interprétée
qui est intervient seul et donc le
corollire de la phrase c'était
interventions économiques or c'est vrai
que le dernier commerce que la
station de distribution de carburant en
milieu rural que tel ou tel équipement
est une relève de intervention
économique c'était très large et et
sûrement que il y a eu une inquiétude à
cause de de cette phrase donc moi
je redis ce que
j'ai ressenti et et vérifié ensuite
quand on reprend le texte
nouveau présenté par la la commission
enfin cet
amendement ce qui pose problème c'est
que l'amendement écrit la région décide
des interventions économiques sous
réserve des interventions économiques
tire de la clause de compétence générale
c'est donc l'ordre c'est la lecture
c'est la lecture je je peux comprendre
que ce ne soit pas l'esprit de la
rédaction de l'amendement mais c'est la
lecture et le résultat c'est bien sous
réserve un président de Région demain
devra attendre que tout le monde aura
émis ses orientations politiques sa
définition de ses intervention et cetera
avant de pouvoir euh définir de ses
propres orentations c'est difficile
je vois très honnêtement pas comment
tout cela va
fonctionner
donc on
a un amendement qui je pense je le dis
pardonnez-moi d'une forme
d'improvisation parce que nous l'avion
pas eu avant d'entrer en séance donc
nous même avons André et moi eu à
découvrir un texte le faire analyser
très rapidement on a quand même un
amendement qui pour les communes
pour les
communes non je l'ai déjà dit donc je
vais pas le dire deux fois donc c'est
bien dans cette de ce sous réserve
de que les région ne pourront plus faire
que ce que les autres n'ont pas fait
donc on va on a un vrai non non mais
j'ai j'ai le droit aussi monsieur le
Président un sourire d'interprétation
c'est l'ordre de l'écriture qui pose
problème je le dis parce que c'est non
seulement un ressenti de la première
minute de la lecture mais c'est une
confirmation après donc vous
comprendrait que cont tenu du texte que
nous avions déposé monsieur le Président
mais madame et monsieur le rapporteur le
gouvernement ne puisse pas
soutenir cet amendement et je pense que
vous l'avez parfaitement compris et je
vous en remercie donc le gouvernement
sera défavorable à cet amendement je ne
sais pas si
André non la parole est au président bas
madame la
ministre excusez-moi mais j'ai peur que
nous n'ayons pas de désaccord mais
simplement un malentendu
entre nous un
texte qui commence par l'expression sous
réserve ou un texte qui finit par
l'expression sous réserve c'est comme
belle marquise vos beaux yeux ou vos
beaux yeux belle marquise
il ne s'attache aucune conséquence dans
l'interprétation
juridique de l'ordre dans lequel on
écrit le sous réserve ça n'a pas de sens
tout simplement je ne comprends pas et
je ne peux que l'attribuer au fait que
vous avez rappelé tout à l'heure que cet
amendement vous l'avez découvert
évidemment au début de la séance et vous
n'avez pas eu le temps de l'examiner de
manière
juridiquement
objective cet amendement madame le
ministre il
explicite les compétences de chacun mais
ne crée aucune
compétence ces compétences sont définies
dans des articles du Code Général des
Collectivités territorial que l'on se
bornait à
énumérer sans en dévoiler le contenu si
bien que la lecture
donnait une impression désagréable
d'être incapable de comprendre la
signification du texte sans aller se
plonger dans le code et aller rechercher
chacun des articles qui étaient énumérés
ce qu'a voulu faire la Commission dans
le souci de répondre à un besoin de
clarification qui s'est
manifester à tous égards et et sur tous
les bancs a voulu expliciter les choses
pour apporter une
sécurité aux différentes collectivités
territoriales elle n'a pas voulu
transformer en profondeur
ce qui était l'objet même de cet alinéa
7 de l'article 2 elle a voulu que cet
alinéa 7 de l'article 2 soit tout
simplement compréhensible dès sa
première lecture sans avoir à manipuler
le code général des collectivités
territoriales et ce faisant elle a voulu
apporter aux différents échelons de
collectivité la garantie
limpide qui leur
manquait point c'est tout et en tous les
cas si on est en
désaccord sur la distribution des
compétences en matière économique avec
cette prééminence reconnue désormais à
la région et bien ce désaccord ne se
déduit pas de l'emplacement du
sousréserve dans une phrase d'une
disposition
juridique merci monsieur le Président
alors pour la clarification des débats
je je vous rappelle que nous avions 14
amendements en discussion commune nous
avons commencé par un amendement qui est
l'amendement essentiel qui a été
présenté par la commission des lois
j'ai enfin j'ai souhaité ù j'ai accepté
qu'à l'issue de cette présentation il y
ait une mini discussion générale où la
la ceux qui voulaient s'exprimer ont pu
s'exprimer pour donner leur point de vue
par rapport à cet amendement et
également par rapport à ce qu'ils
avaient proposé donc je suis obligé
d'aller jusqu'au bout du règlement en
matière de discussion générale je
voudrais demander aux auteurs des
amendements qui vont suivre qui se sont
pour la plupart pour ceux qui étaient là
ce qui était pas là les amendements
tombent pour la plupart qui se sont
largement
exprimés de bien vouloir retirer leur
amendement ou simplement de dire je le
maintiens mais en quelques mots parce
que on a passé beaucoup de temps en
faire c'est c'est très très très bien je
crois que le débat a permis de clarifier
à la fois les positions de gouvernement
et cetera et je serait à l'issue bien
entendu de la présentation des
amendements amener mais ça on le fait
habituellement à Madame la Ministre de
donner l'avis du gouver enfin à la
Commission et à Madame la Ministre de
donner l'avis sur ces amendements
j'essaie de clarifier l'organisation du
débat en me référant tout simplement au
règlement du Sénat alors nous allons
commencer par l'amendement proposé par
Madame lettard au nom de la commission
des affaires économiques oui monsieur le
le Président Madame Monsieur le Ministre
chers collègues je me suis pas exprimé
parce que je ne voulais pas rallonger la
DG comme j'intervenais sur un amendement
je vais pas faire très long mais
simplement l'amendement que je présente
il vient en fait compléter la première
phrase de l'amendement de notre
rapporteur de la commission des lois euh
sur euh la région qui définit les
orientations en matière de développement
économique sur son territoire et
l'amendement que propose que je propose
au nom de la commission des affaires
économiques viser à préciser après
concertation pour son élaboration avec
les collectivités territorial qui ont
été nommés les établissements publics de
coopération intercommunale la fiscalité
propre et l'État tout simplement parce
que lorsque l'on regarde effectivement
on y revient sur cette concertation dans
le déroulé de la façon dont elle va s
élaboré nous voyons bien qu'à l'alinéa
13 et 14 on voit que le schéma fait
l'objet d'une CTAP hein qui sert
effectivement justement à la
concertation avec les EPCI les
organismes consulaires et à l'alinéa 14
on dit que par contre on élabore
conjointement on ne fait pas que
concerter on élabore conjointement
l'idée étant de dire au travers de cette
phrase chapeau qu' n'y a pas qu'avec les
métropole que nous élaborerons
conjointement mais avec l'ensemble des
EPCI merci Madame pour avis euh
l'amendement de Monsieur Favier je crois
que vous avez dit que vous le retiriez
oui il il peut être retiré dans la
mesure où l'amendement de nos trois
rapporteurs serait évidemment adopté
l'amendement de Monsieur adnaud
585 merci il est retiré monsieur le
Président même si les réponses que j'ai
obtenu ne sont pas exactement celles que
j'attendais parce que ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure c'est que les
collectivités de base quand elles n'ont
pas la taille il faut bien qu'il ait
quelqu'un d'une plus grande taille qui
puisse le faire et donc voilà mais moi
je suis absolument d'accord pour
travailler avec les régions sous forme
de convention ce qu'il faut c'est que
nous puissions le faire l'amendement 828
monsieur Favier oui monsieur le
Président c'est un amendement qui
précisait effectivement qui rappelait
aussi le rôle de l'État en matière
d'action économique mais ça a été
rappelé donc par Madame lard à l'instant
dans son amendement donc si l'amendement
de Madame lettard est est retenu
celui-là évidemment tombe l'amendement
168 rectifié et l'amendement 226 tombe
ils ne sont pas là l'amende n'est pas
défendu pardon ne sont pas défendus
l'amendement 654 monsieur colon il est
retiré merci l'amendement
683 représenté par Madame nicouot il est
retiré l'amendement
758 rectifié présenté par leement le
gouvernement il est maintenu la
amendement
169 présenté par Monsieur
grand il est pas défendu celui 227 non
plus le 655 par Monsieur colon il est
retiré le 684 madame nicouo retiré dont
nous nous retrouvons avec trois
amendement et il faudrait que nous ayons
l'avis de la commission pour pour
l'amendement 2 madame lettard
l'amendement 405 monsieur le
rapporteur je je suis assez ennuyé par
cet amendement parce que il faut non non
parce que il faut lire tout l'article
euh quand on commence à dire dans la
concertation B la concertation prévoit
le schéma et cetera c'est tout l'article
qui qui est qui est alors ça il faut le
principe c'est que c'est la région qui
est compétente et non pas
euh et qu'on rappelle quand même ce
qu'il y a dans les textes sur les
métropoles sur les les les
intercommunalités ce qui a été souhaité
par nos collègues mais c'est la
région qui est compétente et on verra
même qu'elle est compétente
exclusivement en matière d'aide aux
entreprises
et je vous assure que c'est faire un
petit peu un procès la commission je le
dis nous
avons bien affirmé mieux affirmé le rôle
des régions que n'était le projet de loi
initial ah si c'était
flou on a précisé les choses pour que
tout le monde soit bien bon on pourra
toujours en discuter mais surtout moi je
ne voudrais pas qu'on dise le
Sénat n'a pas valorisé le rôle des
régions dans le domaine économique pour
ensuite dire et ben on va repartir sur
le projet initial ça oui oui oui oui ça
serait parce que vous savez moi je
connais hein les ruses oui oui le Sénat
fait n'importe quoi comme
d'habitude et puis ensuite ben ça va
être tellement mieux notre schéma
initial qui voilà non mais je le dis
quand même je le dis et je le dis
maintenant parce que parce que il faut
pas
nous il peut y avoir peut-être à ce
momentlà proposer s'il y a des
clarifications proposé les modifications
de texte mais remettre en cause le fait
de dire numéro 1 c'est les orientations
de la région la région à compéten en
matière d'orientation alors bien sûr
concertation et cetera tout ce que vous
dites ma cher collègue comme on le dit
sur tout l'article ça m'ennuie de le
mettre dans le dans le chapeau parce que
ça et oui il définit les orientations
bon ben voilà hein mais on peut pas dire
que que le l'amendement ça colle pas je
vous le dis
franchement sur le plan même grammatical
ça colle pas alors je peux pas
l'accepter voilà enfin la Commission a
pas pu
l'accepter c'est comme ça hein c'est
dommage parce que quand même on est a
travailler beaucoup en accord sur le
beaucoup de choses on a adopté beaucoup
d'amendements de la commission mais pas
celui-là
voilà ensuite monsieur le Président il y
a l'amendement
828 du
gouvernement non de Monsieur Favier
pardon
excusez-moi le 828 de Monsieur pavier on
était
favorable favorable à l'amendement de
Monsieur pavier c'était sous réserve des
missions à combat à
l'état qui existe
encore
et amend amendement 758 rectifié
présenté par le gouvernement j'ai bien
peur que soit défavorable
mais pas
s ah oui ben c'est il est identique à
l'amendement 168 de toute façon c'est un
avis défavorable forcément puisque
correspond
pas si monsieur le rapporteur voulez
supprimer la phrase madame la ministre
l'alinéa 7 deè phrase voulez supprimer
la phrase donc on n pas
d'accord donc quel est l'avis du gver
gouvernement
sur sur l'amendement
405 trèsonnement monsieur président
l'AVE du gouvernement est difficile à
donner parce que si l'amendement
présenté ce matin est voté je vois pas
comment je continue à m'exprimer sur les
autres donc on peut s'exprimer sur les
amendements qui étaient des amendements
à l'ancien texte de la commission
qu'après qu'après le vote de non non non
faut don l'avis du gouvernement puisque
c'est c'est le mode de fonctionnement de
notre instition du coup je vais je vais
donner des des avis défavorables parce
que c'est
impossible de d'amender un texte qui
n'existe pas et puisqu'on nous a annoncé
qu'il allait changer je vois pas comment
je donnerai un avis favorable à un
amendement qui change un texte qui ne va
plus être peut-être donc c'est compliqué
euh sur l'amendement de présenter par la
commission économique par madame
lettard je pense que compte tenu de ce
qui a a été dit par le président par le
rapporteur et comp tenu de ce qui a été
dit ce matin il n plus lieu d'être donc
la je serai
défavorable il me
reste 828 madame la ministre 8 828 de
Monsieur présenté par Monsieur
Favier monsieur Favier pardon
excusez-moi parce que l'ordre des choses
change beaucoup
oui cet amendement rappelle
effectivement que l'éat conserve un rôle
dans le développement économique euh oui
monsieur Favier je ve dire ça ça va de
soi c'est évident donc on peut réécrire
dans la loi ce qui est évident mais
c'est évident
donc voilà donc on ne peut être que
favorable puisque j'ai défendu depuis
longtemps la politique industrielle de
l'état du gouvernement pardon et le rôle
dans la politique industrielle de l'État
généré par un certain d'action du
gouvernement donc je ne peux être que
favorable à ce qu'on le
rappelle merci madame la ministre don
nous allons passer
euh
oui madame lettard très rapidement
monsieur le Président après avoir
échangé avec mon collègue rapporteur de
la commission des lois j'ai regardé
l'amendement 1023 qui va arrivver après
dans l'ordre d'examen du texte et qui
satisfait l'amendement que la commission
des affaires économiques avait adopté
donc je retire mon amendement madame
léard
8 et rectifier son amendement 101 pour
compléter la première fois alors je
laisse la parole là monsieur le
rapporteur vous voulez faire une une
proposition concernant l'amendement 828
de Monsieur Favier non non moi je je la
Commission avait donné un avis favorable
bien sûr à l'amendement mais il pourrait
se transformer en sous-amendement
puisque en fait il s'intègre et Madame
la Ministre ça permet de dire que il y a
des compétences pas seulement de la
région il y a celle de l'État il y a
celle des interco et des métropoles et
cetera donc je me réjouis qui est sous
amendement une partie une partie de la
de l'interprétation donnée à la position
de la Commission des lois tombe de ce
fait et donc il faut absolument que ce
sous-amendement soit
adopté merci Monsieur le le rapporteur
donc monsieur Favier euh qui vous aviez
deux avis favorable pour l'amendement
828 on vous propose de le sous-amender
euh pour l'intérêt dans l'amendement
proposé par la Commission je su tout à
fait favorable à ce qu' notre amendement
effectivement soit raccroché à
l'amendement donc de la commission donc
sous forme de sous-amendement donc je
vais proposer de mettre au voix cette
sous-amendement euh quel est qui est
favorable qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient dont l'amendement
est adopté s le sous-amendement est
ainsi
adopté sous et le
1021 ainsi sous-amendé et mis au
voix monsieur Sueur pour explication de
vote et ensuite Monsieur R
taillo monsieur le le président madame
et monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je souhaitais
intervenir pour
dire que si cet amendement
1021 devait être
compris selon les termes qu'a employé
madame la ministre je ne le voterai
pas je suis très
clair si le sousréserve
de devait être
interprété comme signifiant que la
région ne pourrait intervenir que dès
lors que l'ensemble des autres instance
ce serait déterminé préalablement je ne
le voterai pas et je
considérerai que ce serait un
nonsens je veux dire que le sousréserve
est une clause qui existe dans de très
nombreux textes qui dit qu'on instaure
un droit une capacité une
compéten dans le cadre de ce qui existe
par ailleurs dans le droit c'est
exactement similaire à ce qui existe
dans l'article 2 du projet initial du
gouvernement qui s'agissant du schéma
économique écrit je vous cite madame la
ministre les actes des collectivités
territoriales et de leurs groupement en
matière d'intervention économique sont
compatibles avec ce schéma c'est-à-dire
que l'on dit qu'il y a des actes qui
peuvent exister en vertu du droit
existant qu'il doit y avoir une
compatibilité mais ça n'enlève rien au
pouvoir d'initiatives aux prérogatives
aux compétences instaurées pour les
régions donc il faut être très
clair ce sousréserve n'implique
absolument pas une sorte de
subordination des régions aux autres
instances voilà en tout cas moi je je
tiens à dire que je l'interprète comme
cela et de même que tout à l'heure il
était important de bien dire que si on
supprimait le seul l'adjectif seul
c'était parce que ce texte voulait
marquer la vocation éminente des régions
en matière économique mais qu'il est
évident que pour des raisons concrètes
pratiques les métropoles l'armature
urbaine d'autres collectivités seront en
lien travaill iront en lien avec la
région ce qui n'enlèvera rien au fait
que les régions et le rapporteur l'a dit
et redit seront les seuls à pouvoir
distribuer des aides économiques donc il
fallait
clarifier le sens de l'amendement par
rapport à la suppression du de
l'adjectif seul il faut clarifier le
sens que nous donnons à sous réserve qui
n'est en rien une limitation une
amputation qui est une clause juridique
qui est fréquente dans notre droit et
c'est dans ce sens-là c'est-à-dire le
sens de l'affirmation d'un rôle éminent
dans le domaine économique pour les
régions que pour notre part nous
voterons cet
amendement merci mon cher collègue la
parole est au président
retaillo très très vite pour indiquer à
la suite du rapporteur que personne ne
peut faire le mauvais procès au Sénat de
ne pas vouloir confier aux régions plus
de responsabilité économique d'ici deux
articles nous allons d'ici deux articles
nous allons demander un transfert du
pouvoir sur l'emploi de l'État pour les
régions en faveur des régions ce sera le
seul élément de vraie décentralisation
donc je pense que cela répond je crois
aux interrogations des uns et des autres
moi je félicite le rapporteur et je
félicite le président qui ont élaboré
nuit amment cet amendement rectifié et
pour répondre à l'obscure clarté du C de
cantè de pierrf Colomba je lui répondrai
par une autre citation de Victor Hugo
pour répondre à certains qui s'opposent
et qui veulent s'opposer à cet
amendement rectifié Victor Hugo qui
écrit si bien dans les plis de leurs
dogme ils ont la sombre nuit je félicite
la Commission des loi d'avoir une nuit
claire pour nous éclairer ce matin merci
la parole est à Monsieur
d
oui je je je pense que Victor Hugo était
pour la clarté c'est un peu le sens de
sa vie je suis pas certain que ce matin
V vu les dernières interventions on a
beaucoup avancé dans la clarté et et
notamment alors je ne suis pas un grand
spécialiste du droit le président yest
adore le rappeler même si je pense que
je pense
que absolument en jouant avec les marges
de manœuvre de la institution nous en
reparlerons mais là vraiment honnêtement
moi je suis quand même tout à fait
impressionné par le débat c'estàdire que
nous avons un débat pour donner un sens
au mot c'est l'intervention du président
suur en disant oui mais alors le
sousréserve il faut l'entendre comme
cela donc si nous faisons des articles
de loi qui nécessitent qu'on ait des
débats pour expliquer dans quel sens on
attend les on entend les mots moi je
vous propose qu'on change les mots ça
sera plus simple et trouver un
mot et et moi je je pense que le
sousréserve effectivement ne ne peut
peut difficilement survivre euh à à la
navette ou alors j'ai pas bien compris
comment on travailler c'est c'est un en
tenant compte et ça va plutôt dans le
sens de l'amendement de Madame lettard
qu'elle a retiré pourquoi vous ne mettez
pas en tenant compte à la place de
sourréserve ça serait beaucoup plus
simple beaucoup plus clair parce que là
très honnêtement personne ne va
comprendre cet amendement et j'essaie
moi aussi d'aller dans le sens d'une
recherche de quelque chose ch de lisible
et en étant tout à fait dans la ligne de
Victor Hugo merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à François
patria une minute seulement en fin de
compte monsieur le Président monieur
madames mieur les ministrees rapporteur
tout ça est né d'un
malentendu parce que si on regarde les
textes et la
réalité la loi sur les compétences
des métropoles elle a été votée elle est
existe elle est in changée la seule
chose que l'on demande aujourd'hui dans
la loi c'est que les métropoles se
mettent en accord avec la région pour
mettre leur action c'est la seule chose
la seule chose qui est demandée et pour
se faire c'est la seule chose demande de
le faire alors on veut maintenant dans
le texte affirmer la prééminence du rôle
économique de la région on l'affirme
mais on l'inffirme totalement à travers
son écrit en mettant le sous réserve
parce qu'en droit sous réserve ça veut
dire sous réserve si il y a une action
économique qui est menée et qu'elle n'a
pas l'accord des collectivités
infratérritorial pour le faire elle ne
pourra pas le faire donc elle n'aura
plus le pouvoir économique alors au lieu
de clarté mes chers collègues que vous
préconisez que vous prêchez avec
beaucoup de véhéence on est totalement
dans l'obscurantisme le plus parfait
donc la raison pour laquelle je soutiens
le gouvernement qui est contre cet
amendement je ne voterai pas un
amendement dans lequel il y aura sous
réserve qui infirme totalement le fait
que dans ce texte on a voulu affirmer la
prééminence des régions en matière
économique j'appelle mes collègues et
amis des aujourd'hui des métropole à un
peu de sagesse en disant il suffit savez
les régions qu'ell seront-elles dans un
an mais oui qui sera dans les régions
dans un an hein est-ce qu'à ce moment-là
vous aurez le même langage
qu'aujourd'hui sans doute pas alors je
pense que si on repose sur le fait que
les métropoles garde une compétence
économique simplement leur demande de se
mettre en accord avec la région pour le
faire c'était pas trop demandé même ça
vous le voulez pas alors moi je ne
voterai pas l'amendement merci mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
destregne Merci monsieur le Président la
sagesse populaire dit souvent ce qui se
conçoit bien s'énonce clairement et les
mots pour le dire viennent
aisément on est en train de faire la
démonstration du contraire là ce qu'on
est en train d'écrire d'ailleurs on sait
pas trop ce qu'on est en train d'écrire
on y comprend plus
rien il me semble qu'il serait sage
peut-être de réserver cet article non
non mais non non non attendez
ou de ou de suspendre la séance de ou 3
minutes pour
l'écrire
clairement il me semble que ce serait
sage parce que là on ne sait pas trop ce
que veut dire ce que l'on va voter on a
compris en écoutant les uns et les
autres ce qu'il voulent mais on n pas le
sentiment que ce qu'on nous propose de
voter signifie la même chose il y a un
vrai problème franchement c'est pas une
bonne manière de
légiférer la durée de la durée de ce
débat est l'exemple même de
l'incompréhension qu'il y a entre ce
qu'on lit et ce que l'on entend donc moi
je je laisse je laisse la Commission le
rapporteur en ci avec le président mais
franchement c'est pas clair du tout
alors que la plupart des gens sont me
semble-t-il sur la même longueur d'onde
sur ce qu'il faudrait
faire merci mon cher collègue la parole
est à la présidente Jacqueline
gourou bon je vais pas faire de citation
je vais essayer d'être
claair
1 la commission des lois a vraiment été
toujours sur la ligne de la compétence
économique aux régions bon première
chose deuxièmement il y a les
intercommunalités métropole on sait que
la loi donne des compétences économiques
aux intercommunalité et au métropole bon
très bien alors ensuite moi je comprends
pas bien le truc département là-dedans
je ne vois pas comment ça revient à
l'intérieur donc euh
je crois je crois qu'il serait quand
même raisonnable Jean-Jacques si on
prenait 10 minutes pour écrire le
truc jean-jacqu je suis désolé je pense
qu'il faut le faire parce que là il y a
il y a trop de
réserve
voil monsieur
jarier oui monsieur Président Madame
Monsieur ministre moi je partage l'avis
dequeline gr j'ai l'impression que dans
la discussion d'hier soir les
explications qui avaient été données
assez clairement par Jean-Jacques yest
avaient permis de clarifier les choses
et on était bien dans une logique il y
avait les compétences générales donc les
interventions économiques du bloc local
et il y avait des possibilités
d'intervention par
délégation des
départements en matière économique et ce
matin alors évidemment il y avait le le
problème de la de la la formule elle est
seule compétente bon et ce matin en fait
et bien j'ai l'impression qu'au lieu
d'aller vers la clarté et bien plus
personne ne comprend rien c'est ce que
vient de dire y des train donc il
faudrait peut-être revenir à un texte
qui nous permettrait de mieux nous
comprendre les uns et les autres parce
que je crois que cette fois-ci on n est
pas du tout donc peut-être
qu'effectivement une réécriture euh
pourrait s'imposer parce que là moi j'ai
l'impression qu'on inverse les rôles
puisqu'on considère que la région
intervient sous réserve de ce que font
les autres et ça pour le coup je pense
que ça peut poser problème donc revenons
à des choses claires compéten compéten
économique aux région le bloc local
continue à faire ce qu'il a à faire le
département peut intervenir par
délégation et les choses seront claires
il m'a semblé que c'est ce que disait
jean-jacquesas hier
soir la parole est à Monsieur Kaltenbach
oui je crois que tout le monde est
d'accord sur le fond c'est-à-dire que la
région définit les orientations
intervient avec des actions qu'elle
décide mais que cela n'empêche pas en
parallèle des collec tivités qui ont la
compétence économique de continuer à
intervenir les métropoles les
agglomérations les comités de communes
les communes et dans le cadre de
délégation les départements alors c'est
vrai que si on lui disait clairement
avec deux phrases séparées ça serait
peut-être plus simple à comprendre mais
on voit bien que le sousréserve pose des
problèmes d'interprétation certains le
comprennent d'une manière d'autres d'une
autre manière et que ça ne peut que
créer de la confusion donc je propose si
on peut sous-amender
avec un sous-amendement oral de
remplacer sous réserve par sans
préjudice comme ça ça permet peut-être
je m'adresse au rapporteur de de régler
le problème et de bien clarifier les
choses en disant que la région définit
la région mène les actions qu'elle
entend mener mais en parallèle ça
n'empêche pas les agglomérations les
communes les métropoles de mener elles
aussi des interventions économiques
voilà je crois que le terme sans
préjudice sera plus clair et permettra
de lever toute ambigué et de ce que j'ai
entendu jusqu'à maintenant permettrait
de rassembler l'ensemble de
l'hémicycle monsieur Colomba voulait
intervenir monsieur Y je lui donne la
parole et puis ensuite vous intervenez
voilà je crois qu'il il y a deux
problèmes deux problèmes se posent à
nous du fait le premier le plus simple
c'est que du fait de du manque de moyens
nous craignons que uneir une si si la
région est la seule à pouvoir intervenir
il y a plus personne qui interviennent
et puis il y a un problème beaucoup plus
redoutable et c'est de là que c'est
parti puisque c'est des interventions de
notre collègue
colon les métropoles les métropoles vous
semblez découvrir que les métropoles ont
des compétences en matière économique et
qu'elle
capte tout ou parti des compétences
économiques de la région des
départements aussi d'ailleurs pour
d'autres aspects vous le découvrez
aujourd'hui vous découvrez aujourd
auourd'hui que cet objet bizarre les
métropoles ne colle absolument pas avec
notre système avec l'organisation de
notre système et évidemment on se débat
pour essayer de concilier tout ça c'est
pas un problème de rédaction il y a
vraiment est-ce que vous voulez ces
fameuses locomotives qui vont nous tirer
et amener le développement que sont les
métropoles en laissant le reste du
territoire ou pas c'est ça le fond du
débat alors on ne règlera pas ce matin
par une question de par par un problème
de rédaction on peut tout simplement ben
masquer la difficulté et laisser autant
le temps de de le de le de le résoudre
c'est tout ce qu'on peut faire il y a
une contradiction fondamentale
acceptez-le merci mon cher collègue la
parole alors la parole est à monsieur le
rapporteur je vous rappelle quand même
que dans l'état des choses nous sommes
en train euh de passer au vote vous avez
demandé la parole pour exprimer votre
avis sur le vote d'un amendement qui a
été rectifié hein voilà nous nous sommes
à ce stade de la discussion donc
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez la
parole oui monsieur le Président pour la
clarté effectivement le le terme sans
préjudice est bien meilleur à sous
réserve et d'ailleurs dans notre
amendement d'hier soir c'était sans
préjudice je pense que ça suffit
peut-être même de
trigne ça suffit peut-être à de trigne
pour bien
expliquer et à Jean-Pierre s en tout les
cas aux préoccupations de Jacqueline
gourau de Jean-Pierre s d'un certain
nombre il y a des compétences qui
existent à d'autres niveaux quant à la
compétence des départements on sa peut
s'exercer dans le cadre des conventions
et cetera et donc c'est tout à fait
clair mais la compétence des régions je
le rappelle elle a été affirmée et plus
même par la commission des lois
quiinitialement nous avons précisé après
les conditions dans lesquelles il y a la
coopération entre les interc les
métropoles et cetera pour l'élaboration
du schéma et et vous verrez aussi que
c'est l'exclusivité pour la région des
aides aux entreprises tout ça c'est
clair alors je pense que de à partir du
moment où on dit bien sans préjudice ce
qui veut dire simplement qu'il y a des
compétences d'autres ité je crois que
tout est clair voilà merci monsieur le
rapporteur donc pour avancer je vous
propose don un sous-amendement que nous
allons appeler 1108 proposé par Monsieur
kaltenb puis c'est lui ou par qui que
vous voulez voilà qui propose donc de
remplacer le mot sous réserve par sous
préjudice sans sans préjudice sans
préjudice
voilà je mets sous-amendement au voie
qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient don l'amendement
est adopté je mets maintenant au voix
l'amendement 1021 ainsi sous-amendé et
je le rappelle pour la clarté des débats
par deux fois un amendement de Monsieur
Favier et un amendement de Monsieur
catenbach je mets donc au voix C
amendement
1021 qui est
pour qui est
contre l'amendement est
adopté dont le l'amendement 758
tombe nous passons dans la suite des
débats à l'examen de trois amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
sur l'article 2 l'amendement 409
présenté par Monsieur
Montauger monsieur le Président Madame
la ministre monsieur le le rapporteur
chers
collègues dans la perspective de d'un
aménagement équilibré de l'espace
régional les orientations retenues par
les régions en matière de développement
économique doivent prendre en compte la
nécessaire contribution des territoires
ruraux la notion de de ruralité
n'appartient n'apparaît pas en tant que
tel explicitement euh en début de de
texte de loi euh donc cet amendement
affirme la place que doivent avoir les
territoires ruraux dans le domaine de
l'économie ruraux ou hyper ruraux
d'ailleurs en complément j'y tiens
beaucoup et en lien avec les grands
systèmes métropolitains qui
constitueront de plus en plus on le sait
l'armature l'armature de notre économie
nationale voilà donc pouvoir introduire
à la faveur de de de de cet amendement
euh la notion de ruralité
euh aussi haut aussitôt dans le texte de
loi me paraît avoir du sens et c'est en
soi la la raison de la proposition de
cette de cet amendement merci merci mon
cher collègue l'amendement 829 présenté
par vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue merci monsieur le Président
Madame non Monsieur Je je vois pas
monsieur le ministre Mones ch collègue à
travers cet amendement et et donc ce
complément à l'alinéa il nous semble
qu'au-delà des des attendus de l'article
2 il soit nécessaire de prévoir pour ce
qui concerne les politiques locales de
développement économique des objectifs
autrement plus ambitieux que ceux qui
semblent assigner ici ne serait-ce à nos
yeux parce qu'il ne faudrait pas
réitérer la production des mêmes aements
en cette matière que par le passé à
savoir que les interventions publiques
locales dans le champ économique
consiste bien souvent à se contenter de
socialiser des coûts que les entreprises
se refusent à prendre en charge c'est en
ce sens qu'il nous semble nécessaire
d'inscrire dans la loi ici la
conditionnalité des aides publiques
régionales à raison de l'atteinte ou de
la réalisation de certaines finalités
précises les aides publiques ne peuvent
en effet pas être ind instrumentalisé
pour mettre en question pour remettre en
question par exemple l'un des principes
essentiels du Code du travail à savoir
l'égalité de rémunération à compétent
égal des hommes et des femmes cette
égalité doit qu' doit conditionner
l'intervention économique territoriale
c'est le sens de l'ensemble des critères
que nous souhaitons voir rajouter pour
rendre
l'intervention économique et la dépense
publique plus
efficace et répondre aux besoins des
territoires des femmes et des hommes qui
vivent et y travaillent merci ma cher
collègue amendement 122 présenté par
monsieur le rapporteur oui merci
monsieur le Président le l'amendement
vise à préciser que les spécificités des
différents territoires de la région
doivent être prises en compte par le
schéma régional de développement
économique d'innovation et
d'internationalisation par exemple les
territoires péurbains ruraux ou hyper
ruraux ou hyper
ruraux les territoires de montagne ou
encore les territoires
frontalier le projet de loi prévoit déjà
que les actions prévues par le schéma
régional ne doivent pas contribuer au
des localisation d'activité économique
au sein de la région ou d'une région
limitrophe donc voilà le sens de
l'amendement rapporteur votre avis sur
les deux amendements voilà alors l'avis
je vous le dis il n il nous semble que
que notre amendement 1022 répond aux
préoccupations des deux autres des de
des des deux autres amendements et plus
synthétique
et
donc soit nos collègues retirent leurs
amendements
soit je demanderai la priorité sur le
vote de notre amendement monsieur le
rapporteur quel est l'avis du
Gouvernement monsieur le
ministre sur l'amendement de Monsieur
Montauger le 409 et le 49
rectifié en discussion commune avec
celui de Monsieur le
1022 bon ces amendements sont utiles et
pas seulement au débat moi je pense que
même si leur portée normative notamment
pour le 409 n'est pas d'une évidence
absolue je pense qu'ils peuvent être
utille notamment dans le fonctionnement
des futurs conseil régionaux pour que
les élus régionaux le moment venu
puissent bien avoir à l'esprit qu'ils
doivent s'occuper du développement
économique au sens global du terme de
tout leur territoire notamment des
territoires ruraux et en particulier des
territoires hyper ruraux cher au
sénateur Bertrand donc le gouvernement
hésite entre la position de sagesse et
la position favorable je pense qu'on
peut on peut aller vers une position
favorable sur ces amendements pour bien
montrer que le Sénat comme le
gouvernement ont une préoccupation
commune celle des territoires
ruraux on discute aussi du829 monsieur
le Président de Monsieur Favier oui oui
nous avions le 409 rectifié le 829 et le
1022 sur le 82 29 il nous semble qu'il
n'y a pas lieu de préciser dans la loi
les objectifs sociaux et
environnementaux que doivent viser les
orientations définies dans le schéma
régional de développement économique
d'internationalisation et d'innovation
et j'ajoute que leur caractère limitatif
paraît de sur cro contraignant donc le
Gouvernement est défavorable à cet
amendement 829 favorable au 1022 et au
409 rectifié merci Monsieur le Ministre
don nous allons mettre au voix ces
amendements je vous rappelle pour la
amendement 409 rectifié il fait l'avis
d'un retrait de la commission au profit
de l'amendement 1222 présenté par
Monsieur le le le rapporteur et d'un
avis favorable du Gouvernement monsieur
montuger quelle est votre position
merci monsieur le Président je je prends
l' acte des des des propos de de
Monsieur le le ministre qui a qui a bien
évalué le le le sens s de cette de cet
amendement le le texte de de
l'amendement proposé par la la
commission des lois est tout à fait
compatible avec celui que j'ai proposé
donc je propose voilà simplement de
retirer mon amendement merci mon cher
collègue voilà pour ces débats dans
l'hémicycle sur le projet de loi nôre
pour nouvelle organisation territoriale
de la République qui répartit les
compétences entre les différents
échelons les sénateurs examinent en ce
moment et bien les compétences des
régions en matière de développement
économique vous avez pu le voir les
débats sont très feutrés très
respectueux comp tenu des événements de
la semaine dernière pas question de
faire preuve d'agressivité dans
l'hémicycle mais ces événements pèsent
aussi sur le contenu des débats certains
sénateurs comme les écologistes
entendent bien donner une teinte plus
sociale à ce texte afin d'éviter la
relégation voire l'exclusion de certains
territoires vous pouvez toujours voir et
revoir toutes les séances sur notre site
publsenat.fr très bonne journée à tous
sur les chaînes
parlementaires